la scène se passe donc hier soir il
manque simplement le restaurant brasco
située à cergy c'est dans le val d'oise
non loin de paris
un jeune livreur est pris à partie par
un individu se revendiquant comme
algérien et qui profèrent de très
nombreuses insultes à caractère raciste
visiblement quelques secondes après
avoir été frappés jusqu'au sang par ce
même individu
alerté par les cris de peur et de
douleur une voisine elle elle aussi
noire sort de sa fenêtre et décide de
filmer la scène
sauf que l'individu décide de s'en
prendre verbalement elle en l'insultant
et la menace ont d'abord avec une
capuche l'homme cède et décide de
poursuivre ces menaces à visage
découvert on va vous montrer tout ce qui
s'est passé
on va regarder la première vidéo et bien
sûr on va voir dans un instant le
témoignage de souliers sabine habitat
lina merci d'être là vous êtes l'auteur
de la vidéo témoin et victime de
l'agression raciste à cergy c'est
incroyable quand on voit les images et
et laissait les galères vos employés
vraiment on a tous été très très très
choquée aujourd'hui et gucci benzin
merci d'être là vous avez appelé à
manifester devant le resteront notamment
merci zoubir vous êtes patron du
restaurant brasco à cergy on va voir
votre témoignage également aussi et
aurélien tâche et député non inscrit de
la 10e circonscription du val d'oise
donc vous êtes fans voient donc vous
êtes directement concerné par par cette
affaire alors on va voir la première
vidéo regarde pas ce qui vient de chez
pas qu'elle plaide espèce de petit mêmes
cherchent l'âme je suis sam et à l'aim
la cagoule klépierre la fata ghoul suis
très fier et gardez vous voyez ma mère
tout et on mar y sol pas d'accord voilà
il a traité qui l'a traité d'esclaves
il a fait saigner voilà son sceau du
parterre là parce que le mec il venait
tranquillement la livrée et tous ceux
qui sont dans le restaurant la c1 brasco
alors c'est vous qui filmait les
souliers safina vitamine a et on va voir
joue bien vous avez fourni des images de
surveillance de votre restaurant pour
prouver que mourad apparemment ne
travaille pas dans votre établissement
vous avez nodier on va voir s'il
travaille chez vous on va avoir le
témoignage on regarde ce que nous avons
envoyé on voit les images de l'agression
je vous le dis c'est violent
[Rires]
[Musique]
alors ensuite il ya des dizaines de
personnes bien sûr qu'ils sont
rassemblés dans le restaurant brasco à
cergy tous sont venus chercher l'auteur
des propos proférés et on a une deuxième
une deuxième l'image si les sources
divergent sur le fait que cet homme
travaille dans le restaurant pas on voit
dans une seconde vidéo l'homme ordonné
aux livreurs de partir puisqu'il âge au
site récupérer sa commande comme s'il
était responsable du restaurant
dans cette vidéo l'homme continue
d'ailleurs d'insultés et menacé de
nouveau menacé regarde oui vient le
trouver
t'as vu ta mère je paye un loyer et moi
je suis propriétaire situé à west bay
continue
mais également des dégâts
je l'entends dire tu as ta commande et
ensuite l'offre enchaîne avec de très
nombreuses insultes racistes envers la
personne qui filme la scène envers vous
des mots qui sont très très choquant
regarde elle donné grèce est spéciale
mois merci de tout chemin avec un bateau
là même avec un droit de caisse ne
touche pas au ciel tu pilotes tu pues
l'âme pendant 800 ans vous attendu comme
du bétail en deux est-ce que vous est ce
que veulent un talent dsk vue
l'attendait c'est très très violents et
je vous voyais vraiment ému encore un
est de revoir ccc ces images
racontez-nous hier soir alors qu'est-ce
qui se passe hier soir ce qui m'a
interpellé parce que j'étais en train de
regarder un film parce que j'avais du
mal à dormir
c'est un spectacle heures à 23 heures
d'accord c'est un cri strident mais
vraiment un cri vraiment effrayant j'ai
sursauté j'ai ouvert ma fenêtre et là
j'ai vu un homme étalé par terre plein
de sang
il avait comme un bagage enfin je crois
un sac de livraison de couleur jaune
mais qui essaieront de taché de sang et
partait y avait du sang sur son vélo il
y avait du sang et je sais pas j'avais
pas compris au début quand tu vois
puisqu'il y avait plusieurs personnes
lui et jean quatre personnes puissent
lui ça faisait 5
donc je me suis dis peut-être que sigma
gares entre amis qui a mal tourné
peut-être après de l'alcool voilà une
beuverie mais sauf que quand j'entendais
la propos racistes qu'il disait oh mec
qui était par terre des gens s class
insoutenable voilà je me suis dit et là
c'est comme ça j'ai filmé jeudi vous
tous vous êtes dont le restaurant et a
même pas une personne qui a daigné lever
le doigt alors que l'autre ils en train
de saigner
je suis en train de filmer alors vous
vous êtes dit je vais filmer chiba
c'était au début quand j'ai pris mon
téléphone pour filmer ces gens je me dis
si je lui dis que je suis en train de
filmer bas il va avoir peur depuis il va
lâcher prise sauf que ça s'est pas passé
comme ça c'est c'est les autres qui
l'entouraient qui sont partis parce que
les autres même s'ils n'étaient pas
impliqués dans la bagarre j'ai senti
quand même qui l'ont pas ils n'étaient
pas motivés comme impôts pour aider
celui qui était par terre donc voilà
alors ensuite vous avez été on le voit
menacé insulté
vous avez eu peur en ce moment là
j'avais peur j'avais page et ja je me
posais la question est-ce que tu fermes
ta fenêtre et tu laisses l'autre comme
ça où tu ouvres et bat le côté humain
était plus fort que l'homme ça arrive à
un moment où on fait quelque chose on
réagit moi mon intention vu qu'il avait
sa capuche et le visage
je lui avais dit d'ailleurs retiré voilà
je me dis emmène le quand même arriver
sa capuche et plus puisque c'est c'était
des propos de jean esclave et machin vu
que des noirs peut-être que tu va capter
son attention il va laisser l'autre
quand même en paix et il va se défouler
sur toi pendant que l'autre
il a le temps vraiment de souffler et
que ça n'aille pas plus loin pas c'est
vrai que il y avait des gens de chez
vous que vous étiez tout seul c'est vrai
que cette histoire et il ya ma fille qui
dormait ah ouais c'est pas rêver
heureusement la cave à elle à cet appel
à neuf ans c'est heureusement qu'elle ne
s'est pas réveillé parce que elle aurait
été traumatisée en plus la chambre de ma
fille donne du côté du duo restaurants
ont fait de la rue donc
non c'est pas arriver tant mieux pour
moi parce que je sais pas comment
j'aurais gérer ça parce que même moment
que j'essaie vraiment de tenir en
haleine si on peut dire ça comme ça
j'ai appelé la police et j'ai appelé les
pompiers et c'était beaucoup de choses
en fait je me dis tu lâches pas tu
lâches pas parce que l'autre est née ça
va pas ensuite qu'est ce qu'est ce que
vous avez fait ensuite quand vous êtes
descendus pour voir ce qui se passait et
non troppo ggyc vraiment attendre la
police étant exactement
c'est vrai que j'avais peur mais vu
comment ils étaient enragés parce que en
plus il n'avait pas bu d'alcool donc
c'était plus ils étaient motivés pas la
rage sont une rage je sais pas d'où ça
vient
en plus c'est un jeune homme c'est quand
même bizarre que tu essaies tu auras je
raconte une personne de noix alors que
toi même tu viens du continent africain
s'est passé et c'est incompréhensible
pour moi vous l'aviez déjà vu ce jeune
homme
non mais si jamais non l'amitié en route
parce que vous l'avez jamais vu que
sabine en chassant ou du restaurant où
j'habite juste en haut du restaurant
basque où j allais avant avant c'était
pas le monsieur qui était là c'est un
autre qui êtes j'irai mais j'ai comme
arte parce que je prenais souvent des
trucs là bas et non celui là je n'avais
jamais vu et par contre ce qui a fait je
voudrais vraiment signifie quelque chose
je nul pas j'ai mentionné que qu'il
travaillait dans le restaurant d'accord
c'est lui même qui l'a re fille qu'il a
affirmé enfin celui ci ça comment je
travaille ici
voilà donc chacun y va de
comment si tu me dis tu travailles ici
tu habites ici je vais pas chercher plus
loin vu comment tu était énervé je vais
pas chercher à comprendre si tu parles
de la ville ans il s'est énervé après le
livreur alors vous avez vu le début non
je n'ai pas vu malheureusement alors moi
j'ai pas justement c'est pour ça que je
les ai vus là mais je veux voir extz et
nous quand on revoit les images sont
vraiment on est très très très choquée
je suis aussi insoutenable les propos
sont si le monde espère certainement
abjecte c'est incroyable c'est vraiment
sans une vraie haine qui est d'exercer
ses cinq ans c'est dégueulasse et vous
savez je vous dis quand même le bon
réflexe de camp lui demandant d'enlever
sa capuche en essayant de 2,2 de
discuter avec lui essayé bon voilà mais
vraiment je sais vous avez pas dormi de
la nuit
ah non j'ai pas dans jusque là j'ai
vraiment parce que le matin quand je me
laissais l'erea le premier réflexe est
allé porter plainte
monsieur voilà et puis après j'avais
peur aujourd'hui un peu ouais j'avoue
que j'ai peur pour ma fille alors on est
avec vous dire vous êtes le patron du
restaurant le brasco à cergy qu'est ce
qui s'est passé hier soir ben moi j'ai
pris j'étais content ce qui s'est passé
ce matin au réveil quoi d'accord vous
étiez pas là hier soir pas du tout
d'accord faut savoir que le restaurant à
partir de 21h il ya une seule personne
qui est en cuisine vu qu'on a en
fermeture il ya une seule personne qui
est en cuisine cette personne qu'on voit
sur les images
elle travaille pas dans mon restaurant
l'a jamais travaillé dans votre cas
l'agresseur pour vous ne venez pas il
n'est pas dans votre restaurant
aucunement dans mon restaurant
il a déjà été formellement identifiés
ils ne travaillent pas dans mon
restaurant
donc c'est pas quelqu'un qui bosse dans
mon restaurant en fait il y avait 80
connaissiez se garent pas du tout il y
avait quatre individus qui sont baladés
sur le parvis
à partir de 22h30 et qu'ils voulaient
manger sauf que on ne sert plus en
présentiel ont fait que des livraisons
via les plateformes c'est pour ça qu'un
livreur qui vient prendre une commande
et à partir de ce moment là il ya eu 1
et chaud fort et il semblerait que la
personne qui vous a insulté s'en est
pris aux livreurs pour lui dire ouais
des pour l'insulter et à partir de ce
moment là ils l'ont agressé mais votre
livreur vous le connaissiez ah non moi
j'ai pas vivre un mois
ah non moi je passe quelque part des
plateformes communes à canberra je n'ai
pas d'aigreur moins d'accord donc c'est
un livreur qui est venu récupérer le
sésame d'accord un client et à ce moment
là où il récupère la commande il ya
quatre individus qui qui se mettent sur
lui et qui lui demande qui veulent
intervenir pour rentrer dans le
restaurant que c'est un acte raciste
1 c'est un acteur puisque le racisme
c'est un non mais c'est plus que raciste
là c'est inimaginable ces odieuses qui
s'est passé non mais moi si ce que vous
dites aux gens qui disent que ce lot et
garonne ils avaient ils l'ont dit long
parce que je sais que guillaume genton
ah non moi j'entends vos témoignages et
je le respecte la juste avant l'émission
il y avait des dizaines de jeunes de
cergy qui était devant les studios qui
m'ont tous affirmé que sept personnes
travailler chez vous on a aussi
recueilli le témoignage d'un client
régulier de 5 client régulier de votre
restaurant on peut peut-être l'écouté
qui reconnaître ce jeune homme qui
s'appellerait mois donc et qui avait
déjà un comportement problématique avec
les clients dames alors que moi je je
vous affirme que j a aucun mourad qui a
travaillé dans mon restaurant
aucunement toutes les vidéos de manière
peu pendant quinze jours de mon
restaurant moi de donner à la police
pour qu'ils puissent vérifier toutes les
personnes qui bossent dans mon
raisonnement
tout sera fait pour blanchir mon amour
mon restaurant je vous assure qu'il n'a
jamais travaillé chez moi toute cette
histoire
malheureusement c'est triste pour madame
c'est triste pour le livreur
mais c'est triste pour moi aussi je n'y
suis absolument pour rien toutes les
personnes toutes les personnes qui
parlent de cette vidéo la suisse ce
n'est pas mon livreur ça n'est pas une
personne qui bosse chez moi c'est une
bonne personne qui sont venus ce matin
dans mon restaurant
il ya une dame qui est venu à 10 heures
du matin pour s'exprimer et et me dire
mais je comprends pas je connais tous
vos nouveaux salariés ce n'est pas
possible
quand je vois ça c'est honteux je lui
explique elle me dit oui je connais vos
les personnes qui bossent chez vous il
ne bosse pas chez vous et je n'ai pas
une personne qui bossent en bandoulière
avec un en survêtement dans mon
restaurant
ça n'est pas possible et sincèrement je
vous assure que moi je suis poli à trois
victimes dans cette histoire il ya
madame il ya le livreur et ya moi je
n'ai aucunement aucunement il a
travaillé chien beaucoup plus de
victimes quand on voit des images parce
qu'il assure qu' on est tous assurent
bien je vous dis à tous les outils dont
on dira ce soir et on peut passer images
sont insoutenables et parce que sache où
on va en parler avec benzin dans un
instant cc c'est incroyable ce qui s'est
passé et on a on a un témoignage guillou
ils n'avaient recueilli alors vous allez
nous dire
zoubir monde envie de vous croire aussi
voilà il ya il ya un mineur un client
régulier du restaurant je suis ici
exprès pour surnom mais c'est bien on
vous dit rien sinon je serais pas venu
ici et qui dit que ce ne serait pas un
livre mais quelqu'un qui serait à la
caisse et qui aurait déjà eu des
comportements problématiques ont le
souci à côté pas de souci ils sont
quatre autres contrées longtemps
généralement ça fait deux ou trois ans
plus les notes sont seuls oui j'ai en
plus eu d'exécutions étudiants que les
gens du comportement est ce que est ce
que c'est possible de dire que vous êtes
c'est trahir par un nouveau salarié par
exemple vous vous n'êtes pas sur place
dans votre restaurant et qui a un pote
qui appelle un pote loisirs mais tant
qu'à cependant donner un coup de main et
que vous venez tpo courra du tout c'est
impossible frappe aussi impossible
qu'avec son survêt et sa bandoulière et
ranch et je vous assure que ça aussi je
vous le jure et je vous l'assuré que ça
gênait pas du tout petit j'ai des
personnes qui travaillent à ma caisse
il ya deux personnes ils font rentrer
personne d'autre dans un restaurant 5 0l
un restaurant d'un document il ya la has
à partir de 21h il ya une seule personne
qui prend la tablette et qui en cuisine
c'est pour ça qu'on n'a pas pu assister
la personne qui a eu des problèmes
dehors parce qu'elle ne voit pas ce qui
se passe elle est en cuisine est la
suite une tablette elle prend la
commande est la donne au livreur
j'ai déjà donné d'autres vidéos où vous
avez pu voir que les livreurs ribéry 30
dans mon restaurant etc
ap à ce moment là il ya une personne qui
vide la commande est aucunement
aucunement cette personne travaille dans
mon restaurant et je voulais et je vous
la firme est vraiment vraiment je peux
je peux alors j'espère que la justice
sera faite et vous verrez aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui il ya des dizaines de
personnes qui sont rassemblés dans votre
restaurant bas des dizaines ya eu des
centaines et centaines à cergy tous ont
dû chercher l'auteur des propos proférés
hier soir regarde
sordo des différents menus ma gueule
pourquoi attendre c'est l'histoire de
dignité c'est pas une histoire de se
séparer
c'est vrai que quand on voit ce qui
s'est passé quand on voit si j'en ai
envie de faire un appel au calme et on
est on se dit c'est pas possible d'en
arriver là c'est moi vous voulez vous
dis je les comprends mais je suis obligé
de les comprendre les gens bien sûr ça
c'est horrible ce qui est qui a été dit
forcément on dit on dit qu'il travaille
chez moi forcément je comprends qu'il
vienne et vienne je veux moi je veux que
la lumière soit faite sur cette histoire
le plus rapidement possible
vraiment vraiment je veux que ce soit
fait je veux vraiment que la personne
soit interpellé jours vous avez été
victime quad inde
ah non mais moi je suis victime d'un mec
qui n'a qui n'a jamais travaillé chez
moi je vous le jure je vous le promets
c'est le pire truc qui puisse m'arriver
dans ma vie j'ai tout fait franchement
mon restaurant il est très bien il est
bien notée on a des on a des bonnes
critiques les gens les gens qui venaient
de manger chez moi je n'ai jamais
dérapages cette personne n'a jamais
travaillé chez moi et origine c'est vrai
qu'il a été identifié
donc on va savoir très vite mais
j'entends parfaitement ce que vous dites
néanmoins je vous repose la question
selon des témoignages que j'ai
recueillis vous joueriez peut-être sur
les moustiques qui n'est pas salarié
chez vous ils travaillent pas dans le
restaurant est-ce que c'est pas
quelqu'un qui est occasionnellement
je dirais de manière non déclarés se
diriger dans les yeux travailler puisque
ce gilles verdez je vous dis une chose
franchement sincèrement s'il avait
travaillé chez moi je vous le jure je
l'aurais déposée au commissariat le
matin même si c'était un de mes salariés
c'est insoutenable j'aurais jamais
laisser une personne comme ça dans la
rue
allez à l abandon j'aurai je n'aurais
jamais couvert ne peut pas couvrir une
personne comme ça ça n'est pas possible
et je vous le promets je vous assure
qu'il ne travaille pas chez moi je ne
connaissais pas jamais de la vie je l'
ai vu ce monsieur
jamais de la vie je vous le jure je
cuisine aideront à vous expliquer
néanmoins que des témoins disent je le
reconnais je vois là c'est que je vais
dans cet établissement et je reconnais
cette percée à damman je vous assure que
quand la personne va être arrêté vous le
verrez et le tout va rentrer dans
l'ordre il ne travaille pas chez moi je
vous le jure je vous l'assuré
après j'ai une personne qui bosse dans
mon restaurant
c'est un marocain qui pourrait peut-être
lui ressembler si vous voulez mais ça
n'est pas lui ça n'est pas tout le temps
reste enfin vous savez qu'ils rendent
qui sort demain et maniema qui fait les
plannings je sais exactement qui est
dans mon restaurant à quelle heure est
en danger quand j'ai vu ça
il ya une personne qui passe à la caisse
chez moi qui en arrêt qui est même venu
qui a parlé et qui a même dit aux gens
il a dit maintenant le seul caissier qui
est là c'est moi et je vous assure les
deux personnes de la caisse qui sont qui
travaille chez moi ne lui ressemble pas
du tout du tout du tass on est à 15
jours des ventes en berne à jarry pour
l'écouter gucci benzin qui a appelé à
manifester au devant de brasco qu'est ce
que vous dites à tout ça avant de
prendre la parole je tenais à dire que
la négrophobie est une abomination que
nous condamnons fermement et sévèrement
et la ldh soutien à la victime parce que
c'est héroïque ce qu'est la faim toutes
les victimes c'est à dire elle est là
avec nous parce que grâce à elle il y a
peut être un drame qui a été évitée
parce que je rends aussi hommage à
youssouf a tué et ce week end à son
enterrement
nous allons manifester pour ça tu es à
cause de la négrophobie parce que depuis
tout à l'heure
j'attends j'entends tout le monde parler
de racisme je suis désolé mais au fait
la norme face à la négrophobie qui fait
partie du racisme c'est l'hostilité
ça fait partie d'une race envers les
personnes noires parce que quand on
parle de racisme
ce monsieur qui est devant nous peut
dire il n'est pas raciste
aucun de ses salariés ne peut être
raciste parce que ses amis sont
africains ou sénégalais vous comprenez
mais il peut être être non et raciste
c'est à dire qu' il n'est pas peut-être
dans une haine de race mais vis-à-vis
des noirs donc c'est des agressions
ciblées alors pour commencer je vois que
il ya en élu ou un député ici avec nous
mais nous interpellons l'état les
autorités françaises qui sont complices
aussi de cette montée de négrophobie en
france pour dire qu'il faut mettre en
place d'urgence les dispositifs
législatifs fait social pour lutter
contre la montée les actes de
négrophobie envers les personnes noires
de france et il
le comprendre que si les autorités
continuent de faire les aveugles ça va
péter et nous disons que ce monsieur ce
qu'il raconte il raconte des balivernes
ce sont des balivernes vous pensez que
le monsieur travaille et j'ai mis ce
monsieur raconte ces éléments nous avons
des témoignages même avant d'arriver une
maman une africaine est parti dans son
restaurant commandé dans son restaurant
à peine il a il a bousculé ce mourad se
décérébrés que vous avez vu sur la vidéo
il l'a traitée de négresse calme et non
je vous jure que c'est pas vrai mais je
ne vous ai pas coupé vous ne me coupe
pas la parole ensuite plein de gens ont
reconnu
mourad salariés non déclarés c'est pour
ça qu'il ne peut pas le reconnaître il
est venu il a fourni des images
regardez bien il a fourni des images
qu'on voit l'agression de se livrer s'il
était si on est que ça pourquoi n'est-il
pas pourquoi vous n'êtes pas venu avec
les images avant même l'agression de
tout ce qui s'est passé peut-être 30
minutes ou une heure avant dans votre
restaurant pour prouver que ce monsieur
pourquoi là si vous essayez de vous
dédouaner alors quoi nourrir le faire
complètement mais toutes les images
moyenne à la jolie toutes les images de
la police m'a demandé quinze jours de
réquisition un journal sort toutes les
images pour y lever leur donner toutes
les images et puis la police a déjà
identifié le personnage elle sait déjà
qui sait ça y est ou est-ce que ce matin
j'étais porté plainte moi parce que
forcément je vois je sais que le livreur
a été porté plainte juste avant moi moi
j'y suis allée juste après et c'est
porter plainte aussi contre x parce que
je ne sais pas qui est cette personne je
veux juste pour la retrouve et que cette
personne est le deuxième la deuxième
personne sur la vidéo qui ne prenaient
même pas le temps de venir en aide aux
livreurs qui fuit le travail ça chez moi
toutes ces personnes ne travaillent pas
chez alors il travaillait ou alors
pourquoi dans ce cas lui même le dit
écoutez madame vous vivez avec votre
mari alors comment se fait il que dans
la vidéo il dit
tu habites là avec ton mari l'accord
excusez moi du terme je vais te jeter
s'il ne travaille pas là comment se
fait-il qu'il connaît habituellement
avec jamais vous l'avez jamais vu
restant vous moi j'y vais pas tout le
temps en fait mais bon comme vous attend
vous l'avez déjà vu ou pas mais tel le
monsieur qui l'agresseur non
une autre question on est en période de
couvre-feu les images on a vu et 22h45
que faisait cet homme dehors qui dit je
travaille ici qui dit récupérer votre
commande un autre restaurant alors n'a
rien ay faire ni de résidents glace
comme j'ai dis avec quatre personnes qui
cherchent à se restaurer à 22h30 ce
qu'elle a de partir de ce moment là ils
ont essayé de venir dans mon restaurant
il ya plusieurs restaurants dans la rue
ils ont essayé de se faire un resto eux
de se restaurer personne ne sert à
partir de 21h et à ce moment là c'est là
où ils sont ils ont agressé la personne
qui avait son truc hubert it
je ne sais pas pour quelle raison et
c'est comme ça que ça s'est passé donc
j'ai voulu protéger sa vie n'est pas
sortie mais on n'a pas de questions il
perd jamais le cuisiner mais il est
derrière dans la cuisine tout en
attendant une seule personne mais non
mais tout en souriant
en fait la hausse soit vous nous prenez
pour des cons non où vous jouez sur les
mots c'est à dire une seule personne qui
a un restaurant le kebab
il est en cuisine ils fabriquent ils
livrent ils encaissent l'argent mais on
y arrivera à non mais pas qu'on va pas
lui pas le livreur c'est à dire le
caissier mais le quai si vous savez ce
qu'il fait il est une tablette dont dans
sa cuisine oui ils valident ou il ya une
personne quand j'en vois j'ai montré des
vidéos ou dans les vidéos on voit bien
le livre 30 son sac et quand vous n'avez
pas ramené ses vidéos et ses déjeuners
ce matin jean cyril ce que vous racontez
ça c'est libre à vous mais nous nous
prenons la responsabilité nous le disons
nous appelons notre communauté toute
personne qui luttent contre l'injustice
nous appelons boycott total les
enseignes de brasco ce n'est pas
seulement à cergy parce qu'à un moment
avec plaisir dans cet euro c'est en gros
mais j'ai cru la voilà si vous avez que
ça alors nous appelons au boycott et 6
avez vous refusé d amour j'ai demandé à
quoi cela dérange et non on négocie
juste moi ce que je vous propose la
autorisé la priorité écoute juste que je
vous propose mois déjà c'est qu'on
attendait les conclusions dans quelques
mois voir vraiment ce qui va être dit
sur cet agresseur qui a été retrouvé
dans la vidéo nous appelons bon on va
vite ça faisait un bout la corrida dans
les prochains mois ce sera très dur mais
il n'y a aucun souci nations après coup
ne suis je pense comprendre à bandrélé
décision voilà que vous pensez être les
bonnes mais je pense que là vraiment il
faut un appel au calme l'émotion on
appelle un jour avant nous allons venir
d'eux est conscient que cela manquait
nous demandons tout simplement
l'individu en abc intéressés ça nous
demandant qu'ils soient emprisonnés mais
moi j'suis d'amendé vous savez peut-être
que ça tangue survenait d'accord et que
ça fait un moment que nous demandons à
l'état français de prendre des
dispositifs
vous savez très simple nous demandons
juste de mettre en place dans les
tribunes ont une section de lutte contre
les délinquances sinophone capable de
traiter immédiatement les affaires comme
ça à des peines de prison
des amendes et une re formation de
l'éducation nationale parce que tout ça
c'est aussi un problème d'éducation qui
ont fait l'histoire les gens et des
civilisations
parce que quand on parle de 800 ans on
vous a vendu non en fait foi faut
arrêter de raconter des balivernes sur
dix ont participé à midi l'algérie plein
d'eau un moment notamment à chaque fois
qu'ils y sont et quand on se retrouve
devant vous c'est toujours les mêmes qui
chante jégo dit j'aimerais qu'on écoute
j'aimerais qu'on écoute on y est attaché
députés juste aurélien ce soir je pense
que le plus important c'est de faire un
appel au calme et vraiment c'est
inadmissible ce qui s'est passé dans un
autre restaurant mais il faut pas non
plus que ya une appli vraiment une
escalade de la violence non parce que
j'ai fait réparer ce qui s'observe c'est
que je pense il faut qu'une enquête ait
rêvé pour qu'on sache qu était la
médecine pour ce monsieur
il faut quand taylor hall chelito clank
est allé très vite et moi pour me sa
visite
j'ai aussi déposer plainte ce matin
parlementaire je suis député de la ville
de cergy donc je peux déposer plainte
quand des faits sont commis au nom de
l'article 40 de la constitution
et dès que j'ai vu grâce à madame et je
veux la remercier vraiment d'avoir fait
ce qu'elle a fait c'est elle la plus
courageuse ce soir parce qu'une version
s'est pas démonté elle a filmé elle a
été vraiment exemplaire et grâce à elle
moi j'ai pu porter plainte
grâce à vous si celles ci on parle de
ceux de ce sujet parce que je veux quand
même dire que les agressions quand c'est
à cergy quand c'est comme ça un jeune
homme noir
salim aggar d'aujourd'hui personne enfin
que vous recevez ce soir vous en parlez
donc tout d'un coup à y ait d'autres
médias commencent à s'y intéresser donc
merci à vous aussi la bicici rythme au
dessus et ça ça doit plus se reproduire
ah non jamais il avant d'annoncer vous
dire que ça nous fait de la peine tu me
dire sa nouvelle pour clermont et des
clubs non mais moi parce que j'ai goûté
je vais je suis je suis bien là je vais
finir d'abord faut aussi nous leur
disons dorénavant leurs méthodes pour
les dispositifs ça sera le taux
descendra bien le message à l'état le
monde
on suivra dans l'auto défense est longue
c'est moi qui décide ici des oiseaux
morts vous taisez je vous le dis c'est
pas le moment de dire ça non voilà
l'état c'est faux pas il faut pas se
faire justice vous mais moi je vous le
dis attention les résultats devant sa
vie est menacée ou le montois se défend
tout le monde
qui sont ces légendes gratuit faux pas
des fois on aurait dit que l'état l'état
a déjà pris ses dispositions le
restaurant de monsieur et fermez là bien
sûr fallu la pression des rameaux s'il
vous plaît l'état après ses dispositions
le restaurant est fermé moi je suis
député de la ville j'ai porté plainte
pour que la justice soit faite
rapidement parce que justement je ne
veux pas que ça dégénère
donc votre s en faut pas que ça dégénère
c'est de lutter que sur 1,6 oui monsieur
et joxi il faut que tu es sûr que ça
dégénère pas c'est sûr mais j'ai aussi
pas là pour ça mais moi je suis là pour
défendre les nôtres qui sont victimes
et ça fait trop mais ce système c'est la
faute de la france et la colonisation
mais non la déshumanisation
les blacks c'est toute responsabilité
dans ce moment ce qui se passe dans leur
effectif
c'est pour ça qu'on a porté plainte
rapidement il faut que la police ait
bien sûr tom et qu'ils soient fermement
condamné assuré il ya une colère jusque
là il ne faut pas que ça derrière
j'entends votre combat les racismes
médiatisé pas la colère cergy c'est une
ville où tout le monde vit bien mais
c'est ça mais c'est faux de dire
il s'est d'ailleurs munauté qui
s'opposent démocratie est une vieille et
la joie de communauté il ya deux choses
que nous y est on connaît avec 157
nationalité avec sa station de combat
entre communautés son discours n'est pas
l'us open où le cas elles sont déjà
sinon c'est en tant que député joue en
tant que député du val d'oise
oui avez-vous déjà proposé pour lutter
contre la négrophobie haussant les deux
cas vous êtes tombé sur le bon député ou
alain verdeaux c'est une question que je
vous gagnez contreras si j'ai déposé
encore la semaine dernière une
proposition en bois n'est pas là pour
savoir défi l'extrême droite je fais 516
vais vous dire cergy est une ville qui
m'a beaucoup appris en termes de vivre
ensemble de solidarité autres
n'importait pas des combats maintenant
ce new deal qui est à pékin
moi je vais vous dire ce soir s'il ya
des jeunes qui n'auraient rien n'a
beaucoup qui nous regardent ce soit
ce soir on veut pas d'image comme ça on
veut pas mais je sais qu'en ce cas
d'actes mans à cergy où j'ai plein
d'amis qui avaient pour qui ça se passe
très bien on toutes les communautés
vivent ensemble ce qu'il ya aujourd'hui
et ce qu'il faut faire ça
le calme exercée sur travellers c'est
dramatique
non mais je vous dire gucci nous on ne
veut pas de cette société là les gens
comme dans l'échangé d'insultés des
titres cette dame
quand on voit ce qui s'est passé pour le
livreur on ne veut pas de scène un corps
aussi était là on ne veut pas d'
escalade de la violence
on aimerait vraiment que tout le monde
puisse se réunir qu'on puisse avoir les
responsables et l'aurait ceinturé devine
qu'on arrête d'avoir exactement et qu'il
soit puni parce que je vous dire ça
c'est inadmissible quand je vous disais
que ça me fait de la peine et gucci sait
pas c'est que ça me fait de la peine
pour la société de voir une société
comme ça ça fait de la mène à tout le
monde parce que c'est parce qu'on veut
bien sûr est que mes propos mis à
proférer ce set c'est cet abruti fosso 6
à in amenas major séries l'image de
l'emprise de la libération
c'est assez fou qui connaissait plan de
personnes dans le gouvernement
contribuer avec ce parlementaire à faire
voter des lois je répète encore une fois
pour lui d'être allé voter oui au fait
les formes de racisme pour lutter contre
toute forme de racisme et spécialement
lorsque là nous sommes là pour la
négrophobie ou la phobie qui est reconnu
par le parlement européen n'est pas
d'être là de racisme
nous parlons de la négrophobie les
personnes qui ont été touchées
ce sont l'hostilité envers les noirs oui
c'est comme le thé contre
l'antisémitisme le racisme et les
contres due forme mais le globe c'est
que jusqu'à présent les dispositifs qui
sont là les lois qui sont là ne
permettent pas de protéger les personnes
d'ascendance africaine
quand on a vu au parlement européen que
quand on a demandé à faire voter des
lois pour pro pour défendre pour
protéger les personnes d'ascendance
africaine à au parlement européen 60%
des députés français euro députés
français ont voté contre cette loi
vous comprenez au prophète on n'est pas
là pour chaque fois venir dire que sinon
je veux dire et lui fit moi je suis dans
cette émission alors tout est mieux le
racisme moi j'ai un décolleté un moment
toutes les formes de mattioni on est
contre toutes les formes de xénophobie
on est vraiment on est la seule chose
qu'on veut pas c'est une société comme
celle là ça avant nous je me suis vaut
mieux encore il va merci cyril d'avoir
vos émotions là dessus parce que ça
permet de dire qu'effectivement il ya
encore aussi ddt les deux agressions
ratio et la malaria succédé nuit
heureusement que sur les lattes est
horrible
voyez mes paroles vous avez la semaine
dernière il y avait un autre libéral est
encore traitée
vous avez paris johnny souffle a été
assassiné je prenais cette histoire
c'est absolument indigne donc et c'est
justement oui on est content on sert une
forme de racisme et ses livreurs sans
cesse n'a fourni la police les protège
peu les classes de l'ordination ne font
rien cet accord est une insulte raciste
déjeuner protéger aussi parce que ce
jeune homme qui va être qui va être
peut-être ne plus pouvoir travailler
ils auront droit à rien parce qu'on est
livrée on n'est pas salarié bien sûr
juste réactions en france des courriers
en ligne nous avons mis en ligne et à 3
jours une affaire où un couple a été
victime dans lower de airbnb ils sont
partis pour louer il n'a pas donné les
clés et les vidéos sont disponibles
également sur notre page instagram ou
dans les raves à ce jeune couple est
retraité d'esclaves de sale noir finale
messieurs les noirs n'ont pas accès à la
justice concentrent ensemble qu'elles
ont le maire chanter et les petits vous
en tant que parlementaire que faites
vous alors au choix du genre et des
rares il a déjà tout faire pour que n'y
a pas de ça avance a tué en tout cas
dans cette
dans ce cas précis on espère et on va
suivre d'affaires dès demain même heure
que la personne aura des enfants sur l'
enquête dès demain il sera un outil je
vous demande juste un truc pour
l'instant fait vraiment un appel au
calme aux mêmes c'est que tant que le
restaurant est fermé ya pas de soucis à
dire que le régime sur l'instant on
était à la mairie est juste et gucci on
attend les conclusions de l'enquêté
on va boire moins garni un souci sur le
restaurant sera fermé sur ce la personne
n'aura pas été faite à gazéifier et nous
allons aider la cram et soeurs et il est
éjecté identifié comme athée je vous
avoue à savoir des états rien eh bien il
faut savoir
j'ai mes révélations à vous faire il a
agressé un autre noir sur son lieu de
travail parce qu'elle a un deuxième
travail donc sans mon but est là mais il
a trahi passé moyenâgeux qui tue qui